muy buenas noches pues por ahora las
polémicas En todo caso están digamos un
poco de lado porque
Qatar está ya comenzando pues eh con
bombos y platillos este mundial un
mundial que ha esperado pues desde ese
momento en que se le fue atribuido y
bueno hemos visto aquí alrededor del
estadio todavía hay algunos hinchas a
que eh continúan entrando todo a pesar
de que se les había pedido que
estuvieran a las 5:30 hora local para la
ceremonia de inauguración y por lo que
estamos viendo lo que hemos visto a esta
ceremonia inaugural pues
Qatar está queriendo dejar una huella
tienen tienen a uno de los invitados
como Morgan Freeman el famoso actor de
Hollywood y en esta ceremonia hemos
visto como Qatar está finalmente pues
queriendo formar parte de toda una
tradición de fútbol mostrando las
mascotas de todos los mundiales que ha
habido antes cantando los himnos de las
diferentes al mundial ese bien
escuchábamos el Waka waka de Shakira el
área de Ricky Martin de lo Mundial de la
98 mucho y por supuesto Pero la idea
también han de Qatar era la demostrarse
que es un país abierto hacia el mundo
esa es una de digamos de de de las ideas
de esta ceremonia que hasta lo que hemos
podido ver lo que estamos viendo Es que
finalmente pues es muy parecido a una
ceremonia de inauguración mucho más de
unos a Juegos Olímpicos que un mundial
de fútbol